the Joe Rogan experience you know it's
great that you openly talk about having
these panic attacks because there are so
many kids that I'm sure who are huge
fans of yours who also have panic
attacks and they can't [ __ ] believe
that you guys it with your level of
success could still have these little
battles you know that we've all had so
that's so huge that you're willing to
talk about that and say that that I'm
telling you that happened that was
definitely gonna make an impact on
people I you know I mean once you have
it like the first time I ever really had
a panic attack I had one and then I kind
of didn't have another one until this
moment on that still elusive but the
first time really was in Amsterdam to
London Dan bought some mushrooms
uh and I guess they're illegal there I
never I didn't Dan bought him and
brought him on the we were travelling in
a van at the time and they were giant
fresh mushroom not even dried no man it
was like a meal and then he bought um he
like you guys should take some you
should take some I ate like the stem and
this passive I mean it was i eating a
burrito I was after like 20 minutes I
had for 20-30 minutes is like I don't
feel I don't feel anything and Dan's
like [ __ ] arrest me I eat the rest of
this thing as a massive ass thing and
like just let your sweatiness smells
like portobello mushrooms seeping from
my skin and I yeah I Yelp to the driver
I'm like starting to spin out like how
do how do you get this stop he turns
around he only wore black and his shades
on and I thought I haven't I thought at
the time he was like Satan he's like
drink loads of beer it has a quad tough
[ __ ]
and then I just like in the back just
like [ __ ] like freaking out for like
two hours and finally we stopped I'm
like we got I gotta get the [ __ ] out of
this van this is this is in 2003's a
long time we thank you white knuckling
your girlfriend we get out and like I
think I just think it's the fresh air
man I'm like we stopped at this gas
station in Belgium
and I walk into the bathroom with Dan
and they're like this woman's like
speaking in French like you know I think
it's basically saying that call other
what's a fox you see what's happening
Danny it costs money to pee here bro
another what you think I know man is
that crazy and I'm like [ __ ] freaking
out and I all I had was like 50 euros
and I put it on the tray and Dan grabs
it and puts it in my pocket and then put
second nickel there dude it doesn't cost
that much to be like uh and then we both
start laughing that moment and then it I
turned the edge Oh from that and then it
was an amazing experience we started
being like laughing it like how clean
their dumpster was like this right like
even the dumpsters here clean like
bright red meat off it yeah we eat
really truly dumpster dive here eating a
regular meal but I got that panicky
thing right there at the top and I swear
that [ __ ] opened it up for me man there
was no natural light in the back of the
van also all the windows had the really
dark dark tan black tint oh so we were
just in this panic van yeah need to get
outside yeah I remember when this
sliding door went open it was like when
they went into Willy Wonka's place yeah
all the light came in and yeah and then
it seemed like it was crazy because when
we got back in the van three [ __ ]
hours later like our driver like dude we
gotta go think we've been here for 20
minutes he's like it's been three hours
of you guys look talking about this
dumpster and I was like no way so we we
get back in and dance Dan like I don't
know where his girlfriend I guess maybe
happen at the time he's like do you want
some bubble gum and hey we've been on
tour for a month and I never seen this
bag it was like a trash bag for gumball
oh my god what the [ __ ] happening this
isn't just a music man and so he put on
NWA and I was like we both started
laughing I was like cuz it sounded like
fisher-price music like so plastic and
brittle and like dude this is so bad
this is so awful and then he put on
Captain Beefheart safest milk and it was
like the
most incredible sounding record I've
ever heard it was [ __ ] insane but it
was that experience that first opened up
me ever experiencing that like what the
[ __ ] happening like kind of fight or
flight but for no reason
panic attack thing and I think yeah I I
deal with it mostly but just when I'm on
stage I still get them occasionally if I
come in too fast you saying that it was
started from that trip is the first I've
ever felt it man Wow
do you think you broke something in
there I just think I took away too much
I'm really sensitive to I'm really
sensitive to getting high like yeah I I
just it's not in my system it's not it's
not for me you seem like you could have
been a comic mmm
have you ever thought about being a
comics I don't think I could I like
bullshitting though but I definitely I
know I don't know you say funny [ __ ]
when you have funny observations and
your thanks you have a mean streak um
I'm dan I'm Dan's personal comic that's
basically it yeah yeah he is a coming
but yeah the you think that that was the
first one and then from then it maybe is
opened up the door and because you had
one it makes it easier to have another
one is that how it works
well I was exhausted that day because we
were kids we were kids partying for I
was I'd never been to Europe really we
were in Amsterdam I smoked weed the
night before which I don't do when we
were drinking and I barely got any sleep
so I was super shitty feeling so every
time I'm like basically tired I'm more
prone to that [ __ ] and it happens like
at the airport and I don't like the
airport to me early morning flights it
just it always kind of like that was
really hectic and like everything's
[ __ ] moving around and tired like
[ __ ] this is a [ __ ] miserable and
festivals sometimes they're so crowded
and like but no I haven't had him I
haven't had a problem with him really
but I thought the hypnotism [ __ ] worked
[Applause]